so FBI agent Peter struck has been fired
this is the FBI agent who had this very
intense and bizarre congressional
hearing after anti-trump texts of his
went public and according to strux
lawyer FBI deputy director David Bowdich
ordered the firing last week even though
the director of the actual FBI office
that runs employee discipline said that
only a 60-day suspension would be
sufficient Peter struck tweeted about
the firing when it took place yesterday
along with a picture of a statement he
said deeply saddened by this decision it
has been an honor to serve my country
and work with the fine men and women of
the FBI he also posted a link to a
GoFundMe campaign which as of very
recently had raised nearly two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars already and
he is saying from what I understand pat
he is being upfront that this is both
for legal expenses he expects to incur
potentially if he's gonna challenge this
firing but also just for life right
because he did lose his job and people
at least 250 thousand dollars worth of
donations seemingly coming in because
people consider that to be worthwhile I
think he'll be okay he has the talents
he can speak very well he'll be able to
go on to some on a new job I think he
will and there are a few interesting
storylines to the firing of Peter struck
here the first is that Struck's attorney
is arguing straight-up the FBI violated
normal protocol here they did something
on a one-off basis there's a normal
process that handles discipline it
evaluates what discipline would be
appropriate for FBI agents they
determined it would be a 60-day
suspension and instead the Deputy
Director of the FBI said to quote our
president you're fired
but that to me is not really the big
story the bigger story the second story
here is that you would think now you
can't keep claiming that the entire
Trump Russia investigation is a
politically motivated witch-hunt because
remember as soon as Robert Mahler found
out about these anti-trump text messages
of Peters trucks he removed struck from
the investigation immediately and now
the FBI has actually
above and beyond the recommended 60-day
suspension and straight-up fired struck
so if your argument is the FBI is
looking the other way on anti-trump
agents know Peter struck got harsher
than normal treatment hard harsher than
the recommended punishment which was a
60-day suspension that should be and is
in my mind the bigger story but then of
course this gets us the story number
three Republicans are actually doing the
opposite instead of saying you know what
struck was treated harshly there's no
evidence that he compromised the Trump
Russia investigation period as soon as
Muller found out about the texts he
removed him and now he's been fired
altogether instead Republicans are
saying see struck was fired and that's
evidence that the investigation should
end it's completely backwards and Donald
Trump tweeted about this yesterday upon
learning about the firing of Peter
struck Trump saying quote agent Peter
struck was just fired from the FBI
finally the list of bad players in the
FBI and DOJ gets longer and longer based
on the fact that struck was in charge of
the witch-hunt will it be dropped it is
a total hoax no collusion no obstruction
I just fight back of course truck wasn't
actually in charge of the investigation
and of course the investigation is
obviously not a witch-hunt but this is
how conspiracy theories work and we
actually just met earlier Pat we were
emailing back and forth with Tom wood
who's an expert from Ohio State
University on conspiracy theories and
conspiratorial thought hopefully we'll
have them on this is how the conspiracy
theorists work either way the facts
confirm the conspiracy if struck isn't
fired it's evidence of political bias by
the FBI how could that they not fire him
it's a political witch-hunt that struck
isn't fired struck is fired and now
that's evidence that the investigation
should end because somebody involved
with it has been fired there's this
phrase absence of evidence is evidence
of conspiracy and evidence is also
evidence of conspiracy in other words
whether there's evidence or a lack of it
both count towards supporting the
conspiracy
the conspiracy theorist has concocted
here there is no evidence that Peter
struck acted on his political beliefs in
his role in the Trump Russia
investigation of course his views were
anti-trump there's no evidence that
other FBI agents don't have personal
opinions about Hillary and Trump
obviously they do the issue is that his
text messages look bad because they got
out but even still we haven't actually
been told why he was fired this is a
really important point we're all
assuming reasonably so I would say that
the anti Trump text messages are
ultimately the reason that Peters truck
was fired but the FBI understandably has
a policy of not commenting on personnel
matters they've not said why struck was
fired it's not totally clear struck
knows why he was fired if indeed the
idea is having political beliefs
compromised him well then there should
be of removal however we don't have any
evidence that his political beliefs
compromised him and I wonder if this
would be applied under a Democratic
president if any FBI agent is found to
have ever texted someone or even had a
phone conversation where they expressed
views against that Democratic president
would they also be fired like is that
the precedent we're setting here I think
it's just to protect the reputation of
the FBI and the Muller probe in general
and my thought on this is that
Republicans are being incredibly
pathetic on this like there are dozens
of people working in this investigation
all of whom have political beliefs to
one extent or another sure and these
weren't social media posts they weren't
public statements that Peter struck made
they were just private text messages
like that is a Canadian mountain out of
a molehill molehill texts text messages
are presumably private communication I
mean obviously the NSA knows what what
you're saying in your text messages but
this is like firing someone because of
something they said about Trump on a
phone call with a friend in private it's
much more dubious than a social media
posting we've got to remember that
government employees employees of
private businesses you can be fired for
things you say on social media because
they are public having a protected
twitter account maybe is a little bit
different but Jenner
really speaking they are public this is
very different because these were
presumably private conversations one
other thing here we have to remember
that there was recently an FBI officer
who went to a bar was dancing around
which led to his firearm discharging and
shooting someone in the leg not only has
that guy not been fired he's been given
his gun back and yet Peter struck now
has been fired and were not even
actually told why just think about it
and remember it's all optics and
political posturing